thank you
thank you very much mr bird good morning
uh good morning members officers
members of the public and advisors on
this lovely sunny morning
welcome to this licensing subcommittee
it is the 4th of november
2020 and we're sitting today under the
auspices of the licensing act 2003
to hear an application made under the
act my name is councillor mark durham
and i've been appointed
the chairman for this meeting this
meeting is held under new regulations
which came into effect on the 4th of
april 2020
in response to the kovid 19 situation
and there are just a few
uh additional housekeeping issues to run
through
first of all police could ask everybody
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee
this reduces background noises and
avoids any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live via youtube and recorded
and being present in this meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate you wish to speak
um or you can raise your hand or
or whatever it's difficult sometimes to
keep track of the
chat although miss bird will help me i
will invite you at the appropriate
time members are reminded that apart
from indicating you wish to speak or
that you have to leave the meeting the
chat function
should not be used for questions or any
other purposes
and this is especially important members
i don't want to see any chats that are
not related to
the purpose for which i've just
indicated
um please do not use the rate the the
arrays hand us
it's not available on all member devices
i think it may be now but that's
i'm sure we'll get to you when you
indicate when speaking
and referring to agenda papers please
ensure that you reference a page or the
paragraph number
and lastly if members need to leave the
meeting at any point please make this
known and use the chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting
now if i may uh ask officers taking part
in the meeting to introduce themselves
and we'll start this morning with mr
quelch
uh morning chairman uh committee members
yes
simon quelch i'm a lawyer
in the council and also the legal
advisor to this
subcommittee thank you very much mr
quelch nice to see you
emma's latimer
good morning chair my name's lacey
latimer and i'm a licensing officer at
malden district council
good morning uh miss bird
thank you chairman good morning tara
bird i'm committed services officer for
this meeting thank you
well thank you very much are there any
other officers present and if so could
you please identify yourselves now
nigel dermot sir i'm the lead licensing
officer for malden district council
i probably won't have much of a
contribution what i'm listening in
thank you very much nice to see you mr
dermott um now if i'd like to i'd like
to ask um any other person's present at
this meeting to introduce themselves and
we'll start
with the applicant and mr cooper
good morning good morning mr cooper
um is there anybody else present
um mr burke from the police is also
present i believe okay mr buck
um could you identify yourself please so
we can see you
morning everybody my name is gary burke
i'm a licensed officer for essex police
uh good morning sir nice to see you
thank you for attending
ms bird could you now carry out a roll
call of the members just to confirm who
is in attendance please
uh yes chairman of course and members if
you could just indicate when i call your
name if you're present please
starting with councillor bastinger
good morning i'm present thank you
morning thank you councillor durham
obviously you're present
at councillor stilts
good morning tara i'm present good
morning thank you and councillor mrs
thompson
good morning everyone yes i'm present
thank you good morning thank you
um are there any members in attendance
please
good morning chairman tara cancer stamps
present
good morning thank you very much good
morning council stamp how are you
i'm good thank you sir how are you i'm
excellent thank you very much indeed
okay so we move on now to apologies for
absence miss bird
uh chairman we've got no apologies for
absence
okay thank you very much indeed uh item
four is disclosure of
interest to disclose the in existence
and nature of any disclosable
cunery interests other pecuniary
interests or non-punary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph six to
eight inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
and members i remind you that you're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as you become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now to
indicate and i will invite you to speak
i will start by declaring a
non-pecuniary interest
i have been involved and employed in the
licensing trade for
nearly 40 years i've been i've held the
justices on licence
when they existed and i have held a
personal license
since their inception which i think was
1995.
are there any other members wish to
declare an interest
nothing in the chat excellent thank you
very much indeed
so um item five
is the exclusion of the public and press
we now move into private session
and i move that under section 100 a four
of the local government act 1972 that
the public and press be excluded from
the meeting during consideration
of the following item of business on the
grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraphs one
and two
of part one of schedule 12a to the act
and that this satisfies the public
interest test
um i will now ask committee services to
end the live stream to the public
website
just to add something for the minutes it
is also
also um uh pnc on the grounds of
regulation
14 of the hearings regulations relating
to this so maybe for the sake of the
minutes
both the local government act and the
hearings regulations can be
can be recorded as the reasons for it
thank you uh members can i have a
proposal that we move into
a private session please thompson so
propose i propose that
thank you very much uh we'll agree by
sent not only do anybody disagree
no thank you if you'd like to do the
necessaries
yes i'll just get confirmation that
we've stopped the live feed
you